[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 my name is Kayla Dendy and
I will be your driver on this journey as
always now if you're watching this live
I have some very exciting news for you
later tonight just a half hour after
this class ends there's going to be a
big online match where the st. Louis
Chess Club is going to be demolishing
destroying and otherwise demoralizing
the San Francisco mechanics chess club
so stay tuned for that I'm actually
going to be doing commentary on that as
well and then for tonight's class to get
everybody ready for that big match I
wanted to go over some local st. Louis
chess players players who are a longtime
st. Louis ins players who have been a
part of the chess scene here for a while
and who have made some some waves even
on a national scale in some cases so why
don't we go over these games from st.
Louis legends who are playing for us
tonight against the San Francisco
mechanics up first is a feat a master
that many of you may know already it is
the one and only Doug Eckert board
member here at the st. Louis chess club
and longtime chess player feat I master
and over the board chest international
master in correspondence chess and
actually a participant of the 2009 US
Championship now Doug not only
participated in this championship but he
won a couple games including this game
against the one and only
Melik set Koch Ian a very strong
grandmaster who was competing in that
championship as well why don't we take a
look at that game
it started with E for Doug plays
c5 the big Sicilian we have Knight c3
rather than Knight f3
now knight c6 and Bishop b5 and this is
something a lot of players with white
pieces are doing these days
sometimes this Bishop on f1 kind of
finds itself without much to do so by
developing out to b5 sometimes even
trading off for this knight on c6 very
early on my players solved this problem
before it even becomes one
just clarify position of this bishop
right away now Doug played the main move
which is 94 hitting this Bishop and
removing itself from the threat of
capture the threat of doubling these
pawns for example Knight f3 is not quite
the main move from white a lot of white
players tend to play Bishop c4
preserving this Bishop for a little bit
preserving some control of the d5 square
and that's gonna be a critical point in
this game by giving up this LightSquared
Bishop white may give up a little bit of
this control over d5 that can be so so
relevant in Sicilians so we'll see how
that turned out for Koch in a little bit
later on he played of course net f3 Doug
took the opportunity to snap this bishop
off the board takes takes and now a6 is
a very nice move to just kick this
Knight back to where it came from get
back to c3 get out of my face now
d6 from Doug is fighting for the dark
squares and classic Sicilian style white
continues with d4 anyways we see a trade
trading the C pawn for the center pawn
as is often the point in the Sicilian
and now I'd like you at home to figure
out how you would like to capture this
pawn back either with the knight or with
the Queen and see if you can tell me why
what would you like to do - to take this
pawn how would you do this yeah hello
hello to everyone in the chat harsh icy
harsh I see you in there I see SH hello
hello well Jesus is in the chat happy
Easter everybody alright there's a bit
of a delay I'm assuming you all chose
the most common answer Queen takes d4
and it looks like this may violate some
opening principles bringing the Queen
out so early but that principle is in
place because when you bring the Queen
out early it often is kicked around five
minor pieces in this case due to the
exchange of the b8 night for the f1
Bishop there's no way to really play
knight c6 and kick off this Queen so it
ends up just being a pretty active piece
that being said Doug still does continue
with E 5 to hit this Queen Queen simply
drops back to deep
three and note that while Doug did gain
some time on the Queen he did give up
some control of d5 and that's why this
is going to be such a big battle for
these light squares
luckily for Doug he has a little bit of
an upper hand because that light squared
bishop is already off the board he
continues with Bishop e6 highlighting
the fact that this Bishop is unopposed
on these light squares meaning no light
square bishop can challenge it Bishop g5
comes from his opponent now of course
you don't really want to play the move
Knight f6 here itself pinning you would
much rather take off these dark squared
Bishop s' and leave yourself with a
piece that can control d5 it's all about
d5 early on here white went ahead and
traded on e7 doug played Queen takes e7
keeping an eye on he5 we see Queen side
castles from Koch in now rook d8 defends
this pond which was of course attacked
now rook d2 and Doug does in fact
continue now with Knight f6 and we've
kind of reached the end of the opening
here black has developed all his pieces
he's gonna castle on the next turn and
this is the position we have so I'd like
to ask you all at home what what which
side would you prefer in this position
and and why which side and why and
there's a process that I want to talk
about that you can kind of use to answer
this question for yourself and you can
use in your own games to determine if
you actually like your position and what
you should be doing so which side do you
prefer and why that is the legendary ish
in the chat by the way amir doesn't like
Queen side castles by White's fair
enough
still waiting on an answer here so in
the meantime I'll talk a little bit
about the process you can use to try and
evaluate positions like this the process
I like to use is focused around the
plants in chess you always want your
moves to have a purpose and over the
course of several moves you want those
moves to work towards a common plan a
common goal you want your pieces and
your moves to work together now for
white the obvious plan is going to be to
attack this d6 pawn to put more pressure
on the d6 pawn for black there are
actually a couple plans that we're going
to follow of course you're gonna have to
start with castles but from there you
can come up with some other ideas in
this case I think I actually prefer the
black pieces because the plan is a
little bit more clear and it looks a
little bit more forcing than White's
plan for example white can put as much
pressure as he once on this d6 pawn but
it's going to be difficult to actually
capture and it's not that severe if
black even does end up losing this pawn
meanwhile for black the plan is really
going to be to push b5 and even b4 and
start attacking this King and if black
succeeds in this plan then it's a very
very severe threat its threats to the
King and white is going to be in a lot
of trouble if he isn't very very careful
here so I prefer black and the process I
use to come to that conclusion is to
evaluate the plans and to evaluate which
plans are more severe I think it's a
really useful way to think about chess
positions to come up with who you think
is better and to come up with what both
both both sides should in fact be doing
in the game cotton continued with rook
d1 and black castled as we well expected
now Queen e3 comes on the board from
white he's looking to improve his queen
by eyeing some of these squares as well
as some squares on the Kings side and
now Doug plays the simple move Queen c7
it's a nice improving move puts the
Queen opposite this King puts the Queen
in position to guard both of these pawns
if ever needed and it allows the Queen
to guard b6 as well
kind of evicting this Queen before it
ever got there white now continued with
the move h3 which I think is fine and
Doug played what I think is the best
move which is of course just to play b5
doug has his plant he's sticking to it
he's playing b5 and now after a three
this is where I disagree a little bit
with one of Doug's moves Doug decided to
commit to a different plan than the one
I had already mentioned now I wanted to
ask you at home
how would you go about executing this
plan my plan is to break through with
the move b4 and all that's left to do is
to find the specifics find out which
moves you need to play to get the move
b4 through and the way Doug played was
actually towards a different plan which
I found to be a little bit less
convincing in this idea of b4 so go
ahead try and find it yourself at home
try and find what you can do to play for
b4 as black here
so yeah I'm catching up on some of the
chat here and it looks like a lot of
people had some really good ideas as for
evaluating us particularly particular we
know life or name had a great answer and
pointed out that blacks play on the
queenside his Queen side attack it's a
lot more concrete than whites play
there's this plan of attacking the D
pawn I didn't actually mention the plan
of attacking on the Kings side but
that's what White's gonna go for here
and it's not really concrete how white
is going to achieve that which is why
well I explained is more clear it's more
solid so I prefer the black pieces okay
we have got a couple answers now one
person has suggested the move Queen c4
I'm going to suggested Queen a4 I assume
they mean a five and one person says
Queen c6 followed by a five and B four
now the problem with Queen c4 and Queen
a5 are of course this d6 pawn is left
hanging you can't just totally ignore
this pawn queen c6 I think makes a lot
of sense it's not the move I would have
come up with though I think it's just a
little bit too slow you want to play as
quickly as possible in this type of
position and the way to do that is
actually with the slightly
counterintuitive move Queen b8 which a
mere B has actually come up with now in
the chat so Queen b8 keeps an eye on
this d6 pawn and it's actually preparing
to play b4 immediately on the next turn
so you can imagine white plays some
improving move like a knight h4 for
example aiming for f5 and already black
is going to be breaking through with b4
and I think this is this is more than
enough for a solid advantage for the
black pieces here breaking through with
b4 immediately bonus points to you if
you came up with this idea and realized
it's actually possible to play the b4
move first so if you want to be fancy
about it can actually play b4 in the
initial position and after captures
follow that up with Queen B a when White
has no way to defend this pawn the idea
is more or less the same no so points to
you if you came up with ways to play b4
this Queen c6 idea I'm gonna say is not
bad at all I think actually though it
does feel tactically there's this Knight
takes e5 idea that you do have to keep
an eye on but the the logic was there
this idea of a 5 and B 4 is not bad as
well just some tactical issues the a
queen b8 is a great move to play for the
advantage instead dug kind of switched
ideas here rather than commit to this b4
move this Queen set attack he played
another very logical move and and that
was geared towards another very logical
plan rather than attack the King dog
wanted to fix his only weakness here on
d6 and he did so by playing this move
rook d7
now white did continue with Knight Age
for a very nice active move for white
preparing to launch some pawns and Doug
played the move rook da and so it's
pretty clear now the plan that Doug is
playing for he doubled his rooks on the
D file all of his pieces are controlling
this d5 square Doug wants to play the
move d5 and kind of solve all of his
problems now white realized that this
was Doug's plan and managed to come up
with the best move here to stop d5 which
is of course they move f4 you want to
stop d5 by white not by controlling d5
that ship has kind of sailed there's no
way for white to really gain control of
this Square back what he can do is fight
for the e5 square instead so now if what
if black is so bold as to try to play d5
anyways well he's gonna get met with
this move f5 and this Bishop is going to
be trapped and now there are some
complicated tactics here in fact I think
this move doesn't work and due to d4 so
part of me there what he will be met
with is a capture on d5 and at the end
of the day this a five pawn is going to
be hanging should have stuck with what I
said at first but then I saw f5 and got
excited so okay like I said
countering d5 with pressure on the e5
pawn now of course Doug very good player
st. Louis legend did not play the move
d5 which would lose due to this pressure
on the e5 pawn instead played the nice
move he takes f4 where he's clarifying
things in the center a little bit this
leaves him with this pawn on d6
but what he has gained is one
potentially a target on the e4 pawn and
to a very nice square for
pieces and he immediately makes use of
this with the move Queen c5 I like this
move quite a bit he's cleared off the e5
square and he immediately goes to
improve his pieces by using this square
nine of five no comes on the board for
white and Queen e5 comes on the board by
Doug he's just trying to centralize his
pieces improve his pieces with every
move
this is never a bad way to go about
playing chess Cotchin chose to play the
move rook f2 trying to keep his pieces
active as well and Doug just went in for
a clean trade on this f4 square now
immediately I think I disagree with
Doug's move once again here Doug chose
to play the move King f8 which is just
geared at kind of improving his King
getting it a little bit closer to the
center perhaps preparing for some kind
of endgame for example if if white plays
some nonchalant move
Doug's probably planning to take off
this Knight play the move d5 and just
have his king guard some of these
squares a little bit instead though his
opponent actually made a pretty big
mistake the move I might have preferred
to see from Doug is actually a little
bit more complicated his initial plan
was to break free with this move d5 and
I think it still holds true here that
this is something he should try to play
I think the move d5 is a great way of
equalizing here for black if he five
comes on the board this is really the
only way for white to play for an
advantage still but you're gonna get met
with the move Knight h5 this circle move
out of the way and then d4 and now black
has truly broken free with his pieces
this Bishop which is was for a moment
stuck behind this pawn on d5 now has a
lot of scope again this pawn is
hampering these white knights forcing
them on to slightly less natural squares
for example 94 even Bishop d5 is putting
a lot of pressure on the white position
so it'd been a great way for Doug to get
active with his pieces instead though we
see the move King f8 which is not a bad
move at all I just kind of preferred
this freeing move d5 and now
unfortunately for Melek Cotchin he fell
into
a little bit of perhaps a devious trap
that dog had set now for those of you
familiar with the tactics time class you
may have seen my favorite type of tactic
it's where I have a position on the
board and I ask you at home is there a
tactic here so I'm going to turn it over
to you guys
if you had the white pieces is there a
tactic here can you find a tactic is it
a real tactic doesn't work or is there a
problem so go ahead and for those of you
at home try and figure out is there a
tactic here for the white pieces and
then there's a question about 95 that
I'll go back and talk about at the end
of the game but let's let's stick with
this for the moment is there tactic here
of course this question is a lot harder
than the traditional tactics puzzle
where I'll give you a position and I say
there's tactic here find the tactic in
my version of it I get to ask you is
there tactic here and you have to tell
me if there is or if there is not in
fact a tactic no tactic curious is a
mere be no life her name also says he
doesn't see a tactic and believe it or
not they are actually correct however
Malek Cotchin thought he spotted a
tactic he thought he spotted a tactic
now of course the tactic Malek spotted
was Knight takes d6 with the idea that
after rook takes d6 route 66 rook takes
d6 he would be met with this nice move
e5 forking rook and Knight now of course
while those of you at home I have not
spotted this Doug saw further Doug saw
even further and in this position he of
course has the nice move to save all of
his pieces Emir be spots it the move
Knight d5 this move threatened or
counter-attacks the threat to the rook
with the threat to the other rook and
manages to save all of Doug's pieces and
from here it's pretty smooth sailing
Doug wins a piece with this tactic and
goes on to win the game we'll go ahead
and see how we did it the game continued
with rook F to Luke c6 Knight e4 King e7
King Ditu h6 g4 and now Doug plays this
nice move f6 just getting rid of this
annoying pawn on e5 freeing up the
position a little bit more for his extra
piece we see pawn takes f6 Knight takes
Knight takes pawn takes and now b3 and
the rest of this is just technique rook
F for Doug gets his King active breaks
with the move f5 defends his pawns with
the rook goes ahead and captures here
attacks the weakness on g4 and manages
to take off this pawn and now in these
end games your goal is usually just to
create a passed pawn doug has achieved
that and now
going to push that pawn up the board to
victory so we see that white gets his
pawn rolling Doug gets behind the pawn
and in this position
CACCI and throws in the towel sacrifices
his rook and resigns the game so that's
a big win for the one and only Doug
Eckert st. Louis legend of course this
game from the 2009 US Championship
actually so perhaps Doug is one to look
out for in the upcoming match against
the San Francisco mechanics we'll see if
he can take them down as he very well
took down
Melik conscient in the u.s.
championships all right moving on
another very strong player playing for
us tonight is the one and only feed a
master Talia Cervantes and I asked Tali
a little bit earlier today if there are
any games I should go over and she's
like oh I don't know you know I played
some good games this year I played in
the air float open and in Moscow and I
beat a couple GM's and so why don't we
take a look at one of the many
grandmasters that Talia has defeated on
her meteoric rise up the rating ladder
this was her game from the airflow token
I believe it was round three that she
had against Maxim Lulu Goff ski Lou
Cobbs Lugovoy Russians tough for me but
anyways this game starts with d4 d5 c4
e6 Knight c3 Bishop e7 and this is a
nice line of the Queens gambit declined
where black develops the bishop first
keep an eye on this g5 square preventing
for a moment the natural move Bishop g5
from white and just getting into some
different lines of the Queens gambit
declined
Talia wasn't fazed she simply develops
her night out to f3 we see Knight f6 now
from black and the simple Bishop f4
developing move from white black goes
ahead and castles Talia plays very
natural logical chest just III
developing all the pieces b6 now Talia
chose the third most popular move here
taking on d5 is the most common Bishop
d3 has also been played many many times
but she chose the move rook c1 just
putting on some pressure on this c7 pawn
without committing this Bishop yet to
the d3 square
no black chose the move a six and this
is a pretty strange move actually and I
still don't quite understand it
perhaps black is hinting that he would
like to push this move b5 later on in
the game but it just seems like a waste
of time here I much would have preferred
to see from black a natural move Bishop
d7 just developing out and getting this
Bishop onto an active diagonal instead
though a6 that slightly weird move from
black it does kind of force White's hand
so white goes ahead and captures on d5
we see he takes d5 now and Bishop d3
Talia once again very logical player a
very pragmatic player and just playing
natural logical moves no matter what
opponent she's facing now black chose
the move c5 trying to break in the
center immediately Talia goes for this
interesting structure with D takes e5
and B takes e5 and we have what's kind
of known as the quote unquote hanging
pawn structure now in the position
hanging pawns in this case not referring
to ponds that are undefended the ponds
that are kind of hanging in the balance
with each other these two pawns on d5
and c5 this is a pretty common structure
where they have no pawns to support them
but they are controlling a lot of
squares so now the game is kind of going
to be about if black can use these pawns
to his advantage or if Talia can prove
that these pawns are going to be
slightly weak we'll see how both sides
kind of went about doing that
momentarily white went ahead and just
castled still making very logical moves
the knight c6 from black is hoping to
control the center a bit more a3 is a
nice move from Talia this is a great way
to play against Knights just take away
those squares that they like to jump to
so a3 preventing Knight B for now Bishop
e6 black still develops we see Bishop b1
and this is the point where black gets a
little bit hasty and plays perhaps an
inaccurate move in this position I
wanted to pause for a moment to talk
about some stuff here it seems like this
is going to be a favorable imbalance
for white and the reason I say that is
because white is very accurately putting
on a lot of pressure to these pawns
if black isn't careful for example black
plays a slightly nonchalant move like
rook e8 well you're gonna get met with a
variety of moves including Knight g5
including Queen c2 and you're going to
be faced with quite a lot of danger to
your King immediately so that's probably
why black got a little bit antsy here
and played the move d4 now the problem
with this is whenever you play move like
d4 you have to calculate and if there's
nothing that strong players hate more in
chat they're okay there is nothing that
strong players hate more in chess than
having to calculate calculating is the
worst it takes so much mental effort so
much energy in perhaps maxim had
underestimated his up-and-coming
opponent in just a little bit and didn't
calculate out to the end of this d4 line
it's a common break in this type of
structure to try and push these pawns
forward take even more space but here it
simply doesn't work in Talia very
accurately calculated this one out and
it's the classic case of where the
talent or weight talent can't win if
talent doesn't work hard and so black
had to put in the effort here had to
work hard had to put in the effort to
calculate this line out and my guess is
he simply didn't or he didn't calculate
it accurately enough because Talia
simply captures this pawn on d4 now
black captures back of course there's
still two defenders and two attackers
but then uh-oh sorry of course actually
black captures back with the night we
see pawn takes or a knight takes in pawn
takes but now uh-oh Knight c2 and
there's simply no way to defend this
pawn for black Talia adds another
attacker and this pawn is being fed to
the wolves as they say
so this pawn is just dead and gone now
and white has a very very nice advantage
[Music]
Maxim of course wanted to still try and
keep things a little bit complicated
he went for this nice move Knight d5
putting some pressure on the bishop now
if white is so bold as to capture on d4
it's true and that's you're winning this
pawn but
move Knight takes that for might be a
rude awakening now you have no good way
to capture back as you're going to get
for or yet skewered you're going to get
skewered on this g5 square but Thalia of
course sees this trick plays very
accurately this nice move Queen d3 comes
on the board threatening checkmate g6 of
course is the move and Thalia takes this
moment to simply get her Bishop out of
danger with tempo on the rook on f8 and
the fact of the matter here is there's
simply no way to hold it all together
for the white pieces the best we got Lou
gob score it could have done is this
move Bishop g5 trying to counter-attack
on c1 but the nice move Bishop takes f8
Bishop takes c1 and now the simple
recapture of the bishop and the
recapture the bishop and this pawn is in
fact going to fall simply for free still
trying to keep things complicated though
Maxim went for this nice move Bishop f5
hitting the Queen but this Queen simply
takes on d4 and nothing has really been
gained by this Bishop move now Bishop f6
is the complicated tactic Queen d2 comes
on the board Bishop takes b1 now of
course rather than take back on b1 Talia
takes this time to take on f8 going up
the exchange and this is simply dead
lost for Talia Lugovoy probably had seen
this coming in his head and had thought
that this nice move Knight c3 was going
to save the game for him with some
complicated tactics here where this
Bishop defends this Knight this Queen
attacks this Queen and white can't
really take back on d8 due to the threat
of night take c2 with check a nice
intermediate move for black but of
course I'm sure everybody at home sees
the correct move go ahead and try to
find it for white the winning move here
I'll give you a second okay
I'm sure you all found it of course the
move I'm talking about is the move
Bishop to d6 guarding this entire file
and keeping the white pieces safe black
might continue with a night take c2 will
simply take this back and if you take on
d6 will take them b1 guess what at the
end of the day I
one not only upon but in exchange in the
complications in the game black tried 94
of course this is simply nothing Queen
d5 comes on the board and it takes T six
takes lambi one white is still up the
exchange and the game continued for a
few more moose Thalia just brought her
hooks into the game and after rook takes
deep for the GOP's court threw in the
towel and simply resigned so I don't
know if the San Francisco mechanics are
watching but if they are I bet it's time
to start sweating here because we've got
a couple of players who routinely just
beat grandmasters just beat up on him
all day long
not only grandmasters but strong
grandmasters so a very nice game from
Thalia servantes taking out maxin
another classic case of the stronger
rated player higher rated player not
putting in the effort not calculating
accurately and the lower rated player
all you have to do play logical chess
play logical moves calculate when you
have to and you can upset some very very
strong players okay moving on we have a
game between Julian Kirilenko and
Michael movie are Julian of course a
long time st. Louis and played for us in
the pro chest League was the star of the
show in the protest League finals a
couple years back in fact clinching the
entire finals for us with his game
securing the world championship for st.
Louis we're gonna take a look at a game
of his from I believe the 2018 US Open
that he played against this
international master why don't you check
it out he started with the nice move d4
d5 c4 c6 we have a slob defense Knight
f3 from Julian Knight f6 and now III and
this is the quote unquote quiet
variation by Julian he doesn't try and
do anything crazy get this Bishop out he
simply develops these pieces defends
this pawn and plays very natural logical
chess and this is a favorite style of
mine you don't go crazy
you don't go for crazy imbalances you
play chess the way it was meant to be
played you develop your pieces you
defend your center you support your
pawns
and the rest kind of plays itself in the
game movie art went for the move Bishop
g4 which Julian responded to with this
move h3 now a bishop takes f3 is a
playable move but Moyer went for Bishop
h5 instead now Julian simply develops
with the move Knight c3 e 6 and then I'd
like you at home to try and find the
move that you would play here with white
go ahead take a second see what you come
up with there are a couple options and
there's really no wrong answer here
aside from a few obviously frog moves
but let's see if you can find the move
that Julian played in the game all right
we remember yeah I've got my gloves
we're staying safe stay in sanitary here
yeah Julian of course in og of the
channel that's one word for it
he learned chest at the st. Louis chess
club I believe kind of grew up playing
chess here along with myself and yeah
he's he's a familiar face at the st.
Louis chess club to be sure
so we have a couple suggestions in the
chat one person says this move Queen B 3
that's a perfectly fine move you
highlight that the bishop has kind of
vacated the Queen side putting some
pressure here Bishop d3 is also a
perfectly fine move getting developed
Queen c2 not a bad move either Bishop e2
also very common c takes d5 is a
perfectly fine move as well you're all
coming up with very natural logical
moves I can't get mad at you for that
the move that Julian played in the game
though is fighting for a bit more he
actually chose to play it leave very
ambitious G for breaking this pin on the
Knights and going after this
LightSquared Bishop and this is a great
way to go for and imbalance pretty early
on in the game now this is an opening
line that I'm pretty sure Julian had
prepared in advance of course breaking
out with this g4 idea is very
double-edged and can go wrong for you if
you're not careful notably here White
has not committed his King to castling
kingside
if he had then this g4 idea would be a
lot less safe you don't really want to
be doing this if your King has already
castle over there as the King still sits
on e1 though and black doesn't seem to
be getting at this King anytime soon it
gives Julian some freedom to play moves
like g4 to go after this Bishop so
Bishop g6 the natural continuation of
this plan is actually to continue with
the move Knight e5 and going after this
Bishop directly now Knight d7 is forcing
White's hand if he wants to take the
bishop he more or less has to do it now
and so Julian does taking on g6 and
black takes back on g6 now we see a very
interesting imbalance where black has
this nice pressure on this h-file White
has the extra Bishop to his name and a
little bit more space on the Kings side
Julian actually followed this up with a
nice move g5 forcing this Knight off of
this f6 Square and black could have gone
back with 98 instead he went for this
move Knight e4 and this really clarifies
things in the center directly Julian
captures this Knight
and now he needs to defend this pawn so
he plays the move h4 and believe it or
not we are still well within some
opening theory here the move Bishop b4
check comes on the board black gets
developed as quickly as possible
Bishop d2 and now Queen a5 black is
getting his pieces into the game a3
comes on the board Bishop takes d2 Queen
takes d2 Queen takes t2 King takes D 2
and now f5 and I'm going to call this
more or less where the opening prep is
kind of coming to a close maybe Julian
had a couple more moves still in mind
but this is more or less kind of the
starting position of this middle game or
even endgame you could call it at this
point so what's going on here well
there's actually quite a bit for one
there's this imbalance of Bishop versus
night for two there's this imbalance of
this pressure on this h-file and thirdly
there's this strange structure in the
center and on the Queen side now this is
one that is actually going to end up
favoring the white player I'm going to
claim there are a couple really strong
high-level games from this position
there was a game between Wesley so and
Dave navara in the champions showdown
blitz of last year actually and there
was actually another game between ding
Loren and yeah Ivan Sarich that happened
in the 2017 world rapid then had both
actually come from this position and how
those games continued both started with
this game as well c5 is White's choice
you want to lock down vias Queen side
structures take even more space away
from black and lock these pawns on light
squares in these pawns on dark squares
such that this bishop becomes a little
bit more active now rather than allowed
this bishop come attack the 6 pawn black
in all three games went for this nice
move e5 well actually sorry only in this
game did black go for e5 I wanted to
highlight that in the game that Wesley
so played against Dave Navarro Wesley so
actually ended up winning and let's take
a look and see how that game went and
that game Dave Navarro shows this movie
Rick d8 white gets the King off the D
file stepping out of these threats with
King c3 now II five comes on the board
as we saw in our game here now b4 and
black takes on d4 white takes on d4
black goes for 9 f8 now Bishop c4 is a
nice move by white kind of hampering
this Black Knight for a little bit King
g7 and now rook d1 and this really
highlights the plan that white should be
going for here white wants to break with
this move
d5 this is the winning plan for white to
advance his play now in this game
96 ended up not quite being enough for
Dave navara d5 came on the board takes
takes rook d7 and now Bishop takes c6
King takes c6 takes takes rook d1 and
this ended up being a favorable end game
for Wesley so perhaps King 7 would have
been the accurate move to kind of save
the game for Dave Navarro but after king
c7 this rook came into play and ended up
eating all of blacks pawns and Wesley
thought went on to win that game now
that's one of the three games from this
position and that started with rook da
now in the other game this is a game
between of course ding Lauren and Ivan
search that actually ended in a draw
this is more or less how black should
play black started with the move King e7
now after Bishop c4 once again it's all
about d5 black played the move rook age
7 and this is a nice idea from black
starting to put some pressure on this
age pawn white chose rook h3 to give
himself the opportunity to play wreckage
1 if need be now rook d8 from sorry Ivan
C rich in this game King c3 as we
already saw be 5 B 4 takes takes and now
Knight of fate and white went for this
f3 idea and it ended up not quite being
enough for him in this game now you'll
notice the common theme here and both of
these games that high level players
played with black you'll notice that
black ended up taking on d4 and that is
actually a really really important thing
here because now after Knight to e6
white is more or less forced to take on
e6 if he wants to play for an advantage
the reason for that is this Knight is
now putting pressure on these dark
squares in the white camp so black needs
to insert this move he takes d4 and I
takes d4 to weaken these dark squares in
the white camp to four swipes hand into
taking on e6 now let's see what happened
in our main game here that Julian played
and our game if I was still played b4 is
a natural continuation King e7 Bishop c4
playing all the same moves that white
should be playing now tonight a fake
came on the board very natural King c3
rook d8 rook d1 and now here is black
ski mistake in order to maintain the
balance black needed to take on d4
followed by Knight b6 if this is what he
wants to go for that way he can put this
pressure onto the white dark squares
instead what we see in the game is 96
immediately and I'll bet you can guess
what the winning move for white is here
that's right it's the move d5 you step
out of the way of this pawn and leave
black with a much more awkward structure
where this Knight cannot put any
pressure on to these dark squares and
from here it was more or less smooth
sailing from Julian it was very very
accurately played in game C takes d5
bishop takes d5 and now these three
pawns versus these two pawns are going
to be enough for white to actually go
ahead and simply win this game
b6 was played in the game King c4
supports these pawns from behind takes
on c5 takes on c5 Knight c7 from black
now Bishop c6
activates this Bishop and it opens up
this D file a little bit we see King e6
take on d8 take on d8 this rook gets
active on the other open file now in
rook d2 but Julian isn't so worried
about these pawns he simply wants to
promote this C pawn 96 was played now in
rook takes a seven-night back to b8
bishop
ates rixie to check came up to see three
actually and now Rick takes c5 is not
going to be enough here at for black as
his Kings side totally collapses and the
game was soon lost with these Kings side
pawns coming down the board and Julian
promoting by force so very nice game
from Julian pearl Aiko here to win
against this international master this
was a very actually accurate game of
chess Julian I think had a lot of prep
going in and then he executed the plan
perfectly and converted nicely once he
got that advantage straight from the
opening so definitely one to keep in
mind here look out for Julian as well in
today's match as he will also be playing
for us all of these players are going to
be playing for us now with these last
few minutes I wanted to go over a game
from a slightly weaker player than these
first three players I went over I'm
talking of course about Jonathan schranz
the big leader in the video Department
here at the st. Louis chess club he's
actually also going to be playing for us
here tonight against the San Francisco
mechanics now as a joke I was going to
go over Jonathan's game against me from
the all-in match I was gonna call it the
greatest win of his career the only time
he managed to defeat me over the board
but I actually chose instead to go over
a game from his past year way back in
2013 he played a fine gold now not been
fine gold but instead been fine gold son
Spencer fine gold and we'll see how this
game went for Jonathan it was actually
really impressive game from the video
department manager d4 Knight f6 c4 e6
and Jonathan went for some cattle and
type positions with g3 looking to being
kind of this bishop black continued with
d5 now simply Knight f3
very common cattle and stuff and black
went for an early D takes c4 Jonathan
simply continued with Bishop g2 and now
Bishop b4 check comes on the board this
is a common move from black to try and
displace our or misplace one of these
minor pieces from white
really anyway you block this check isn't
entirely comfortable
Jonathan shows Bishop d2 and this looks
like the most natural way to do it but
now you're slightly interfering with
your other pieces maybe these pieces
would like to to see a little bit
instead we're stuck with this Bishop on
d2 now there's a couple ways to play
Spenser Feingold actually chose the move
a5 defending this Bishop on b4 white
went for castles and black played a
pretty dynamic move here move b5 and
this move has seen some play
historically but it's not the greatest
move to be honest with you of course the
obvious drawback to it is it opens up
this diagonal and this diagonal is very
very relevant here this rook still sits
on the a8 square and there's going to be
a lot of tactics that Spencer has to
look out for
now with this Bishop so see if you at
home can try and find the reason that b5
is a bad move there's a move here for
white that more or less gets a pretty
winning advantage straight out of the
opening so go ahead take a minute see if
you can find the kind of winning move
for white
it's France I've been told it's France
I've been sure and I've been saying
trance my whole life been I'm sorry
you know actually I've had conversations
with Isaac I'm not convinced at Shawn's
I've heard otherwise I think I've heard
otherwise okay
I've been told this trance alright
there's anybody at home see the winning
move anybody at home someone suggested
95 someone is asking is see six week yes
but that's not the end of the story
someone typed XD in the chat I think
that's not a chess move they're trying
to write they're just laughing at me
a4 has been suggested and a4 is actually
the correct move here 95 is a pretty
common way to try to take advantage of
this diagonal but in this case black
could simply move the rook and you
haven't really created any threats with
95 however a4 is creating some very
devastating threats on this pawn on b5
already now due to blacks lack of
development he's going to have some real
problems with this piece in particular
it's kind of coming under fire from all
directions here and it might not look
like this rekon a1 is putting a lot of
pressure onto this rook on a 8 but you
would be surprised now in the move I
played this move c6
and white is actually now completely
winning see if you can find the winning
line the continuation here for white to
just win this chess game put Spencer out
of his misery how do you do it how do
you win the game how can it be done I'm
dying to know you have to do something
now or else black is going to be able to
play a move to kind of consolidate kind
of fixes his mistakes
what can be done
so yeah aaseesh has it mati has it Ellie
has everybody has it we move is simply
to take this pawn on b5 now of course if
black recaptures on b5 we have this nice
move Bishop takes b4 and that's how the
zircon a1 does come into play now you
might be wondering well what if black
inserts this nice move Bishop Bishop
takes d2 and it's true that black can
insert this if white takes back with the
knight which might seem natural
well black takes back on b5 and actually
has a really nice position
but unfortunately white can take back
with the other night and now there's
some devastating problems on this
diagonal and black cannot fix the
structure by taking back on b5 like I
said this sort comes under fire from all
directions if you take on d4 here well
you're gonna get met with a few
different moves for example simply
Knight a3 is a great way to get into the
game you can imagine something like this
would happen and the white pieces are
just walking all over in the black
position here with threats coming onto
the board from all angles in the game
though Jonathan ended up missing this
and instead of taking on b5 just
developed with Knight c3 and so missed
his chance to put Spencer out of the
game early on but fortunately for
Jonathon more chances we're to come
later in this actually very interesting
game just wanted to highlight this
opening misstep that Spencer had made
and how Jonathan could have taken
advantage of it so goes to show you it's
never too early to start thinking and
start calculating in your chess games
opportunities to win can sometimes come
as early as move 8 okay the game
continued though Spencer went ahead and
castled and now Queen b1 was Jonathan's
idea it's slightly strange it's a little
bit of a strange maneuver but it makes
some sense Jonathan wants to put this
rook on to d1 and support his Center in
that manner Queen b6 now from Spencer
and we do see rook d1 from Jonathan very
logical continuing with this plan this
should be 7 now Spencer finally develops
these Queen side pieces and Jonathan
takes some space in
Center with E for nigh bt7 from black
and Jonathan just continued with the
move e5 kicking this Knight out of its
nice home on f6 this of course gives
black the d5 square in exchange though
Jonathan with this sneakily placed queen
gets to make some threats on the Kings
side continues with this move Knight g5
of course checkmate is difficult to stop
so Spencer stopped it with the only way
he could with this nice move g6 now of
course g6 does not come without its
drawbacks the drawbacks of course being
whenever you push this pawn you very
severely weaken the dark squares around
your king so for the rest of the game
look to see Jonathan trying to take
advantage of these dark squares this is
going to be the theme of the game he
played this align to weaken these
squares and now these squares are weak
he's going to go for an attack and try
and get at Spencer's King Queen e4 was
the natural continuation and it's what
was played in the game you get the kick
the Queen over to the Kings side to
start making these threats with this
nice pun on e5 to support your attack
King g7 by Spencer is actually a little
bit strange it's true that this King for
the moment does help defend some of
these squares it allows this trick to
kind of swing over to AJ if need be
but by placing this King on to g7 we're
gonna see that much later down the road
Spencer actually runs into a little bit
of trouble due to this King's placement
and I'll talk about that a little bit
more when we get there to start with
though Jonathan continues very naturally
Queen h4 makes a threat only good way to
stop it for black is to play this move
h5 which of course further weakens the
black Kings position he's kind of
holding on for dear life now trying to
keep everything shut down on the Kings
side now I want you at home to try and
find Jonathan's next move it's actually
a really really good move it's an
impressive move that kind of made me
want to go over this game honestly it's
a principle that you might not know
about and it's one that
is very very useful very useful so see
if you can find Jonathan's next move
what can you find
also hello to dorsa maybe dorsa can find
Jonathan's next move best move in the
position best move in the position here
instead of g6 could he have played f5
I think f5 might leave behind an e6 pawn
you got to be a little bit wary about
playing at five in positions like these
g4 g4 is actually not it g4 is not it
geforce natural but g4 is not going to
be the answer here let's talk about g4
though the problem with g4 is that it's
simply not really threatening enough the
move rock h8 is going to come on the
board and if you're not careful black
might actually take you and get this
rook into the game get these rooks a
little bit more active so Rock h8 is is
pretty much defending so not g4 not g4
here not 92 not Knight takes c6 not 94
nobody can find the best move that
Jonathan found in this game like I said
it's it's a really impressive move it
shows a lot of understanding from
Jonathan and that's why I chose to go
over this game so not a single person in
the chat has found the move dorsa they
need your help
what's the best move dorsa i don't know
if she's still watching Doris is here
but does she know the best move in this
position
Tristan says Knight takes d5 he's
approaching the truth he's approaching
the truth so let's think through it
logically get ready here I'm about to
spoil the answers so we want to get rid
of this night why do we want to get rid
of this night well we want to bring our
night into the game as a lot of people
were suggesting 92 is a very natural
move to bring the night into the game
however this night does a really great
job of controlling all these squares as
well as putting pressure on the
queenside and while we're attacking on
the Kings side Spencer is going to be
looking to expand on the Queen side to
push these pawns forward to create
threats on this side of the board to
kind of divert our pieces back that way
so if you take a look at the position
you really slowed down you see that this
Bishop is not really contributing to our
attack it's kind of stuck here on g2
it's looking at this clogged-up diagonal
it's not going to do much from f3 you
know what most it can kind of sacrifice
itself on h5 so the logical move you
want to close things up in the center
you want to slow things down on the
Queen side and you want to open up a
path for your Knight to the Kings side
of course the best move that I'm talking
about is this move Bishop takes d5 it's
a really great move from Jonathan it
locks the center and allows him to
freely divert this Knight over to the
Kings side and this is a really nice
idea to keep in mind in your own games
when you're attacking on the Kings side
you want to do what you can to first
slow things down on the Queen side and
lock things up in the center so that the
opponent's pieces kind of get stuck on
the other side of the board now
unfortunately for Jonathan Bishop takes
d5 was a really nice move but he didn't
continue it in the best manner so by
taking off this Knight he actually
manages to take off this b5 pawn as well
when you take off this b5 pawn black
streams on the Queen side are kind of
just totally dead here if black wants to
regain this pawn he has to take back on
c3 but after B takes c3 well white is
kind of winning on both sides of the
board here for example Queen takes b5
rook be one Queen c6 and now a nice move
Queen
for look at how these pieces are locked
out of the game they cannot come to the
aid of the King and now moves like 94
well I guess not 94 but let's just play
move for black moves like Knight f3
heading over to h3 heading into h6 these
are going to be devastating and black is
just totally dead lost here this closing
up of the center really does the trick
for Jonathan unfortunately though this
nice move a takes b5 was needed to kind
of cement this advantage instead
Jonathan went immediately for nightly 2
and now things are a lot more complex a
lot more difficult Bishop takes d2 did
not actually come on the board it looked
like the most ant removed to me but
black instead played this move rook h8 a
pretty defensive move not a terrible
move at all he just wants to defend a
couple of these squares Knight f4 was
the natural continuation from white I'm
not gonna get too mad at this move and
now rook a e8 is a pretty defensive move
from Spencer he's kind of locking things
down at all costs he's getting his
pieces back to the Kings side as much as
he can but now actually
Jonathan once again missed his chance to
lock things down on the Queen side you
always want to be looking for these
opportunities to cut off your opponent's
play in this case he could have done so
with a couple different moves you could
have taken on b4 and after a takes b4
continuing with a5 giving black this
slightly awkward structure that's not so
easy to mobilize or he could have
actually again just taken on b5 and
after Queen takes b5 just continued with
Bishop takes before Queen takes b4 and
then this a pawn is once again going to
be a little bit more difficult to to
mobilize instead though Jonathan didn't
touch the Queen side at all instead
continue through with g4 now both sides
seem to miss on this turn that Queen
takes d4 is actually a playable move now
it wasn't playable on the previous turn
and due to this nice idea of well 1 this
winning a queen also this move hits this
Queen there's a variety of reasons why
that move doesn't work but after the
move g4 well this idea doesn't
no longer works because this Queens
cutoff and this idea no longer works
because this nights hanging so slight
mist up here both sides missing this
Queen takes d4 tactic but we can't get
too angry at them instead H takes G for
was played Queen takes G for and now
Knight f8 Spencer is doing what we call
the turtle he's putting all his pieces
around his King and hoping to God that
he doesn't get checkmated jonathan
played a slightly strange move king h1
trying to double up on this g file once
again kind of just needed to take off
this Bishop on b4 relieve a little bit
of this Queen side pressure but king h1
instead and Spencer go ahead takes off
here and plays b4 and this is kind of a
thing that Jonathan should have been
looking to avoid now after B 4 C 3 is
going to come on the board and there's
going to be a lot of pressure on the
Queen side that Jonathan has to deal
with so he no longer has the free attack
on the Kings side because he does have
to worry some what about these Queen
side ponds the game continued though
with rook g1 and now Spencer
unfortunately loses the game here with
his next move believe it or not the best
move in the position I'm willing to bet
none of you at home are able to find it
if you want to pause and try to find it
for a second you're welcome to if not
here's the answer of course the best
move in the position is King g8 what
else and you might be thinking that's
absurd why would anybody play King g8
well the reason is there's this awkward
maneuver with Queen f3 and into f6 with
check that is going to come on the board
later in the game and this problem of
having the King on g7 allowing these
tempo moves moves like Queen of 6 with
check moves like Knight takes c6 with
check this is what ends up losing the
game for Spencer so in this position g8
is actually a better Square for this
king rather than g7 instead that we see
c3 and now after takes takes in rook c2
Queen b3 rook c1 the problem for black
is yes he broke through on the Queen
side but now you'll see he had to divert
both his Queen and his rook away from
his King and this allows jonathan to
break through with his winning tactics
now once again if you want to pause at
home and try and
the winning move you're more than
welcome to if not here we go it is of
course the move clean f3 looking at
these weak squares in the black camp and
there's simply nothing black can do
about it you can't guard both of these
squares at the same time Spencer didn't
even try
you played Queen takes a for snatching
his pawn on the Queen side now of course
the nice continuation you sacrifice this
knight on e6 Knight takes c6 Queen f6
check King h6 Knight takes f7 with check
King h7 and Jonathon just takes off the
rook simple enough for me rook takes h8
comes on the board and now Queen takes
c6 takes another free piece and what do
we have here well Johnathan's up in
exchange and this King is simply getting
check mated Queen takes d4 was played
Queen f7 is check King age 6 rook takes
c3 makes some threats against this King
this move comes on the board with check
simply king g1 queen of five is trying
to hold on but this hangs a bishop which
Jonathan simply captures d4 now comes on
the board rook to c8 trading off rook h7
Queen back to cheat - no d3 Queen g3
King h58 to c3 Jonathan just taking
things as slowly as he can making sure
he's not blundering anything keeping all
of his pieces safe d2 queen h3 is check
now if you take this piece you simply
get met with another check and then
white saves this rook so instead simply
King g5 but now Queen g2 check King age
6 rook h3 check King g7 Queen b7 check
and this is where Spencer feingold
decided to throw in the towel of course
no matter where he goes rook c8 is going
to come on the board and he's going to
be dead lost so that's all I have for
you tonight with these four games from
for st. Louis legends now if you're
watching live be sure to stay tuned in
another 30 minutes our big match against
San Francisco is going to start all the
players you saw in these games tonight
they'll be playing it's definitely going
to be worth watching
and hopefully you'll learn a little bit
more about the st. Louis chess scene a
little bit more about the type of chess
st. Louis is really capable of that's
all for me tonight
thank you so much for joining me and I
will see you next week on the road to
2000 goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you